I want to bring in Jeremy Siegel the
professor of Finance at the wharton
school at the University of Pennsylvania
also author of stocks for the long run
who has said over and over again on this
program professor that we will see doubt
20,000 by the end of this year so does
that depend on a perfect earning score
by Tech professor well certainly
anything that's selling for a high price
earnings ratio 25 30 or higher you need
to be perfection to keep your stock
going but I don't think we need
perfection for the market to continue to
go we're selling around 18 times
earnings and don't forget the first the
first quarter has been terrible in terms
of GDP we're going to get GDP about 1%
so 18 times the the first quarter
earnings combined with extremely low
interest rates which are not going to
rise that much this year we don't need
perfection for that I think to get to
Dow 20,000 by the end of the year but we
do we do need some things to happen and
that is for economic growth to improve
for the dollar not to continue to soar
in the markets we're looking for
stability in in the oil price yeah and
and a rise in productivity ok but so
Jeremy here's someone who might be on
the other side of this who is getting a
little bit worried doesn't say we need
perfection but we need at least earnings
growth okay so David Einhorn at green
light sent this letter out to his
investors and he says he's worried about
how first-quarter earnings have shaped
up so far we were supposed to be up
about five percent he says it looks like
we might be actually down by that much
and he says in his letter he says quote
this level of earnings degradation poses
a risk to a market trading at a premium
multiple of earnings assisted by record
high margins what about that level of
fear well ok first of all a lot of the
earnings two things there any shortfall
by the rising dollar forty six percent
of the sale
of the sp500 our sales outside the
United States we've had a twenty percent
increase in the pro in the price of the
Dower over the last six months right
that is HUGE headwinds that are coming
that that are already coming and by the
way we'll probably still feel a little
bit of that even in in the second
quarter secondly as I mentioned one
percent gdp growth with the likely
negative productivity growth that's not
typical of the economy that's also
putting pressure on those earnings and
don't forget the oil price collapse has
devastated the earnings of the the
multinational oil company so these are
what I call one-off events I'm actually
pleased how earnings have come in this
first quarter I think we've got about an
80% beat rate on this first quarter
earnings given these headwinds so I
don't think that that means that the
next three quarters are going to
continue to have those headwinds strike
our earnings ok so it's an asterisks for
you then Jeremy it's an it's an asterisk
for me exactly and that's why I said I
mean I can stand another five percent
rise in the Dower you know that's about
it if it continues to soar I mean the
Fed will have to give some sort of
communication listen guys we're not
going to be as aggressive as as you
think because the rest of the world says
we're the only you know central bank
around that is even thinking of raising
interest rates right now and and all the
all the money is flowing into our bonds
in our capital and that is really very
very difficult for our firms that are so
internationally oriented if I read
between the lines of what you've been
saying professor these last few minutes
is it sounds like you know because we
had build ugly here at our Bloomberg
headquarters yesterday he expresses
confidence that the economy is going to
improve he said look you know he's kind
of like with you okay first quarter kind
of hard but it's going to get better the
rest of the year but it sounds like
you're saying to me that we may not even
get an interest rate rise this year I
think the probability is yes the market
is putting a
a little over 50 50 on September and
listen effect you know Fed Funds at 25
to 50 basis points which is a one in
done situations not going to scare me it
I don't think it's going to scare
investors that long-term interest rate
is far more important for investors than
the short term interest rate and it
really looks like that 10-year bond is
going to be around two percent likely
this year and it may be well into next
year that's not scary for investors